I might have just found out what's
holding up Stargate
this is a biggie welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
so I've been telling you that over the
last couple of weeks I've been speaking
to a source that I've had contact with
for months and they have given me really
great information about what's going on
in Amazon and and whole what's going on
at Stargate this person's been able to
give me information that I've been able
to tell you guys months before it made
it anywhere else and they've been a
really reliable source over the 12
months that Sidetrack has existed
I've been able to give you a few little
information like how Mark Fergus and
Hawk hostby are doing some work for
Amazon to try to figure out how this
franchise would move forwards but
like I said at the time when I shared
that information we still don't have any
news on who the showrunner would be now
my source told me at the time he is
absolutely sure a showrunner must have
been approached because it makes no
sense for them to do any work on a new
franchise unless that showrunner has
been approached Amazon been trying to
find their Alex kurtzman somebody that
would not just create a new show but
that would oversee an entirely new
franchise and I'm being told they might
have found that person so I could say
now where I actually got this
information so again this source is
something I've spoken to for a very long
time they're the first person that ever
came to me with information about
Stargate they used to work for MGM they
don't anymore they now work for an
agency that actually gives them access
to even more information which has been
amazing
but they have not got this information
firsthand they just come from another
source so basically my guide was talking
to another guy
who then gave him this information now
he says that this person he was talking
to should know this information so he
said this person actually does work for
Amazon they work in a position that
would allow them to know this
information so he actually specifically
actually over a beer in a bar in
Hollywood which actually is now all the
best information comes out told him
about this information and My Guy
believes him so
what it has exactly been told well he's
been told that a showrunner not only has
been approached but has verbally agreed
to take over the Reigns of the new
Stargate series
so why isn't it been announced was my
first question well apparently this
person is actually working and is
contracted to another show currently and
cannot agree any new contract to move
forwards with Stargate until that
contract is completed it sounds to me
like this is a contract with a
competitor and there'll be something in
that contract to say that they can't
have those official conversations at
least with another organization until a
contract comes to an end but I'm just
speculating there but the sources
basically said very clearly
this person who they have decided to be
the showrunner cannot sign a new
contract with Amazon until their
existing contract is lapsed so that's
what's holding up Stargate people it's
simply a contract thing and once that
contract actually finish work on the
project they're doing now hopefully we
might actually start getting some really
solid information from Amazon
so my next question was when is this
supposed to happen and guess what they
said
Christmas
there does seem to be a little bit of a
perfect storm happening here that
there's lots of little bits of
information and we always seem to be
getting the same date that around
Christmas or the New Year something is
going to happen so
my next question
who who is this person that they've
decided and is it Brad Wright oh by the
way if you do like the content please
consider hitting the join button and
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
you can also go to side dashtrack.com
and pick marvelous merchandise all of
these little things really help the
channel also if you're new to the
channel like subscribe hit that Bell
notification and share the video
wherever the hell you want
is there any possibility it's Brad right
well
it was obviously very clear that MGM
wanted Brad Wright to show run this new
project when they asked him to write a
script it was very firmly in mind that
he would be the main man it makes no
sense to do any preliminary work or
pre-production work until you have a
showrunner it's like opening a new
company and deciding not to bother
hiring a boss until you know like six
months into the work getting done it
makes no sense so even though Hawk host
B and Mark Fergus are doing some
preliminary work some trying to figure
out how this show on this franchise
would work it would be at least
unofficially under an existing
showrunner this showrunner unofficially
may have already had conversations with
Amazon about a direction and that sort
of thing but also the work that Hawk
host B and Mark Fergus are doing is just
to create one a show Bible so they are
looking at what happened with
um Stargate before and creating a book
of information that then the new show
road I have to stick to so we get Canon
and also then trying to do something
with direction from Amazon about where
they would like the TV show to go so
even if the showrunner comes in later
he'll have this resource it doesn't
necessarily mean he'll follow it to the
letter
so I asked again could it be Brad Wright
they said almost certainly not as far as
they know Brad Wright has no current big
contract that he is obliged to continue
with is they basically said that there'd
be nothing to stop Brad Wright moving
forward to this now if he wanted to so
it seems less likely that it's him so I
said is there any clue who it is because
well Amazon are notoriously secretive
they don't know who the person is and
I'm gonna put my hand up here that's
annoying that we don't know who it is
but my person but my source did
speculate he said and the person that he
spoke to has told him that he was told
so this is like third hand knowledge
that the fans will be very very happy
about the person that's been picked then
that got me thinking I'm back to a rumor
I heard a very long time ago that
actually Amanda Tapping was going to be
the showrunner and that this was sort of
suggested by Amazon to MGM as early as
summer last year so that would kind of
fit what we're talking about here now
even though Amanda Tapping has finished
work on Fort Salem she has apparently
signed up for another TV series she has
apparently signed up to be the executive
producer for another series called
synthesis season zero now I don't know
exactly what the position of that might
be but if it is something that
potentially her contract runs through
until the winter maybe that is the
project that's holding all of this up
but according to IMDb that's not even in
pre-production yet so it seems unlikely
so that is the one spanner in my theory
but whoever this person is that has been
put forwards as the new showrunner
they're currently busy doing something
else I would love you guys to get in the
comments now if you have any suggestions
people that could run a project of this
scale that are currently busy filming or
contracted to be working on something
else at the moment but also that
somebody that according to the source
would make the fans very happy it's got
to be a name we know right it's got to
be somebody that's either worked on
Stargate before or that as I say like
Amanda Tapping actually appeared on the
TV show because if they were able to get
a man to tap in to do this I would be a
very very happy boy so if this rumor is
true what does it mean for Stargate well
it means that the first of the dominoes
has been pushed over
we have potentially a showrunner even if
that cannot be announced for a couple
more months they have the person that
can run the show they have the boss they
have the captain of the ship now all we
need to do is actually build a ship
around that Captain but hey
first things first and it looks like we
might also have people that work at
Amazon in Hall cost me and Mark Fergus
who are very good at setting up new
franchises and doing this type of work
also working on the project again if
true just wow this might be the really
big first step towards getting Stargate
back in our screens it's a slightly
boring managerial step but still a very
very important one
but if this rumor is true then Brad
Wright is out of the picture he will not
be the new showrunner and he will
basically not have anything to do with
any new project
how do you feel about that get into the
comments so if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
also if you enjoy the content please
consider hitting that join button
because that really supports the channel
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]